there's a bill that's trying to be
passed that says foods that have mRNA
technology in them need labeling mRNA
for pigs started developing in 2012.
it's been used in pork since 2018. the
pork you've been eating since 2018 has
mRNA technology in it it's made by
moderna and Merck the way it was
designed is there's a baseline product
which is called the delivery method and
because it's mRNA and it's custom they
respond to each unique virus by creating
this custom portion that then gets
injected into that flock of pigs that's
custom portion which is the active
portion has no requirement for safety
check from FDA this Baseline was
approved went through all the vigorous
whatever is required it's a custom
product so how can we possibly approve a
custom product we have to immediately
respond to whatever the new virus is so
this thing does not require approval and
this is why the state of Missouri
they're saying no we don't understand
what this does yet please put a label
what is a label claim this may alter
your human genome